[Música]
diez años después es de la muerte de
Hugo Chávez su chavismo sigue en pie y
la popularidad que tuvo el mandatario en
vida sigue arrastrando a su partido
socialista Hugo Chávez fue una muestra
de caudillismo perdurable siempre
polémico a veces errático y muy
beneficiado por la Bonanza petrolera
pero esas mismas ideas que impulsó
mantienen la polarización en el país y
la crisis económica sigue siendo brutal
Aunque eso podría cambiar gracias a la
Guerra de Ucrania y al nuevo enfoque de
Estados Unidos vamos a conectar con
Rafael Ramírez ex ministro de pedevesa
de Hugo Chávez y embajador de Venezuela
ante la ONU fue uno de los hombres más
cercanos a Hugo Chávez frías bienvenido
Gracias Rafael por estar con nosotros
gracias Un fuerte abrazo este décimo
aniversario puede ser una buena ocasión
para que revisemos que eso y el
socialismo venezolano Hugo Chávez lo
dejó cimentado pese a las predicciones
de muchos y a las burlas de las
analistas y al aislamiento internacional
y su heredero
permanece en el poder y ese es de nuevo
un personaje con el que el mundo se
quiere relacionar Nicolás Maduro está de
nuevo en el mapa Empezando por Estados
Unidos
Mire yo creo que
con el chavismo
se acabó con Chávez es decir
Nicolás Maduro no representa el chavismo
Nicolás Maduro en estos diez años ha
desmantelado todos los logros y la
conquista del presidente Chávez tanto en
la economía tanto en el desarrollo
social tanto la industria petrolera si
no es correcto decir que el chavismo
continúa con maduro El sentimiento
chavista es una cosa distinta en los
últimos son de opinión dan que Chávez
todavía tendría el 40% del soporte
popular del apoyo popular pero este
gobierno el gobierno Nicolás Maduro se
ha dedicado a desmantelar la Revolución
bolivariana y por supuesto a traicionar
todo lo que fue su legado y su obra no
existe más la obra de Chávez en el país
lo que hay es un país en ruinas por la
acción de este gobierno que yo lo
catalogó con un como un gobierno de
derecha no es un gobierno socialista
bien Hablando de opiniones Hugo Chávez
fue un líder sin dudas lleno de carisma
usted lo estaba diciendo ningún líder ni
en el pasado ni en la actualidad Ha
logrado los niveles de popularidad que
aún después de su fallecimiento mantiene
Hugo Chávez pero también usted
mencionaba la polarización del país que
aún hoy Venezuela no ha podido superar
incluso podríamos decir que se ha
profundizado más que queda hoy de esa
revolución bolivariana
Mira el gobierno
la desmantelado te puedo poner algunas
cifras nuestra economía estuvo creciendo
el año 2002 era una economía de 600 mil
millones trescientos mil millones de
dólares con el gobierno maduro se ha
reducido en 84% la producción petrolera
cayó de tres millones a 600.000 barriles
actualmente todos los programas sociales
desaparecieron no existe más es decir
aquel fervor que si existiendo el pueblo
venezolano y que se extendió en América
Latina o la revolución bolivariana
Sencillamente ha sido trastocado por el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro yo creo que
ha sido una tragedia para el país la
muerte del presidente Chávez sobre todo
que lo haya sustituido un gobierno como
este una cosa muy importante que este
gobierno además de su pésima gestión al
frente de la economía ha convertido la
violación de los Derechos Humanos en una
política de estado algo que no sucedía
con el presidente Chávez nunca sucedió
Yo estuve a su lado durante más de 12
años como ministro de petróleo y Bueno
fui testigo nadie me lo contó fui
testigo de primera línea de Los
Tremendos esfuerzos que hicimos Y cómo
logramos bueno pagar la deuda social que
teníamos con el pueblo venezolano pero
ese ha sido un proceso truncado la
revolución venezolana ha sido
traicionada
hay quienes dicen sin embargo que tiene
mucho que ver el éxito de Chávez con el
Boom petrolero de lo cual usted sabe
mucho más y que no es culpa todo de
maduro sino que también hay unas
herencias de Hugo Chávez que luego
repercutieron en los gobiernos de
Nicolás maduro Usted qué opina sobre ese
tema y sobre los problemas económicos
que vive hoy el país
No mira nosotros dejamos un país
funcionando el promedio del precio al
petróleo desde que asumió el presidente
Chávez se ubica en 53 dólares el barril
hay que recordar que cuando nosotros
asumimos el poder en el año noventa y
nueve el precio del barril estaba en
solo 10 dólares nuestra sexta petrolera
fue a partir del 2008 que el precio se
ubicó por encima de los 100 dólares del
barril Y eso duró hasta el 2010 maduro
incluso he disfrutado de mejores precios
del petróleo que el presidente Chávez
pero la gran diferencia es que nosotros
después
petroleros fuimos capaces de mantener la
producción de petróleo en tres millones
de barriles día y con ello obtuvimos
ingresos suficientes para sostener
nuestros programas sociales y para
comenzar a cambiar el modelo rentista
petrolero que no dejaron instaladas las
transnacionales petroleras en el país
los problemas de la economía venezolana
son únicas y exclusivamente
responsabilidad de Nicolás maduro yo fui
viceministro de economía durante su
gobierno no y le hice un conjunto de
propuestas justamente para bueno paliar
la situación de precios el petróleo que
era negativa en lo en 2014 y maduro no
hizo nada no tomó ninguna decisión
Nosotros le dejamos miles de millones de
dólares en fondos en los distintos
fondos del país y todo eso fue fue
gastado fue
se lo comieron pagaron deuda pagaron a
su socio acabaron con la economía le
entregaron al al control de los privados
o sea esto es responsabilidad maduro
maduro ha tomado la política de culpar a
Chávez en su desastre no maduro ya tiene
diez años en el gobierno es su
responsabilidad debe asumir
la Venezuela actual No se podría decir
que tiene o goza de estabilidad política
la oposición lleva varios años
fragmentada el oficialismo pese a Todo
se mantiene aunque sea bajo una figura
que usted ya no reconoce como un
chavismo puro pese a todos siguen el
gobierno Cuál es el futuro que usted
augura para el pez
bueno el pezuk tiene que repensarse y
tiene que separarse del maurismo porque
eso es un movimiento contrario al
chavismo yo creo que maduro se ha
mantenido en el poder bueno
violando la constitución en las leyes
haciendo trampa Pero además por la
violencia ha cometido miles de
violaciones a los derechos humanos y es
el primer país de América Latina que
está ante la cpi el acusado de de
crímenes de lesomanía después la
violencia que se sostiene maduro no es
capaz de ganar ninguna elección nosotros
los venezolanos los vamos a sacar del
poder por la vía constitucional es decir
midiéndonos en las urnas electorales
con todos esos elementos que usted me
está diciendo por favor amplíeme un poco
más que Qué es el panorama que usted
encuentra se dará en las elecciones en
Mira yo creo que nosotros los
venezolanos primero se impone la unidad
de todos los factores el chavismo Sigue
estando presente en el corazón del
pueblo somos un factor muy importante y
bueno y y tenemos que unirnos al resto
de los factores políticos y sociales del
país para desalojar esta dictadura esto
Esto no es chavismo lo que está en
Miraflores es un movimiento distinto es
una expresión violenta y atrasada de la
derecha política y económica que le ha
impuesto al país un paquetazo terrible
en el orden económico y que ha destruido
ha saltado y destruido todas nuestras
instituciones yo siempre Bueno he
promulgado he propiciado la unidad de
todos los venezolanos pero en torno
Bueno a un conjunto de de elementos
programáticos que están allí la
Constitución las leyes de la República
la defensa del petróleo bueno el interés
de del social por encima de cualquier
otro la soberanía del país todo eso
tenemos pueblo rescatar nosotros ahora
tenemos que reagruparnos bueno y volver
a luchar para recuperar a Chávez su
legado y con ellos recuperar a nuestro
país pues mire Yo le agradezco mucho por
entregar a France 24 su punto de vista
sobre la realidad de Venezuela y
quisiera finalizar con Una última
pregunta sobre este Hugo Chávez
visionario no el mismo Que formó el
programa lo presidente en una época en
la que estábamos lejos de las redes
sociales que fue casi un Mesías para la
población venezolana y que de todas
maneras está todavía en la mente del
pueblo venezolano y en su historia
Sí porque es una historia muy reciente
hicimos cosas extraordinarias Bueno yo
mismo estuve al frente de misiones
extraordinarias misiones de Educación
construcción de más de seiscientas mil
viviendas para los pobres poner el
petróleo al lado del pueblo es decir
nuestro pueblo fue protagonista y
testigo de un período extraordinario de
cambios políticos y sociales a pesar de
toda la intolerancia y toda la
confrontación política Chávez es un
líder que trascendió a Venezuela un
líder latinoamericano es un líder
petrolero es un líder de los países del
Tercer mundo de nuestro pueblo yo me
sigo identificando chavista
profundamente chavista el chavismo
original el chavismo del plan de la
patria y del socialismo y creo que
nosotros volveremos a contribuir a la
reconstrucción de nuestro país pues
nuevamente Rafael Ramírez exministro de
pedevesa de Hugo Chávez y también ex
embajador desde Venezuela ante la ONU
gracias a usted por aportarnos su punto
de vista y su visión de lo que es el
chavismo gracias a nuestros televidentes
continúen con nosotros hacemos una
pequeña pausa y ya volvemos con los
titulares
[Música]